donald trump has thankfully been missing
from the public eye almost completely
since leaving office 14 days ago today
and by the way
two weeks already joe biden has been
president it doesn't feel like it it
feels like he was just sworn in
yesterday but it's been two weeks
trump's been missing but his son eric
trump is quickly
challenging his dad for the most
humiliating
and cartoonishly farcical interviews i'm
not totally clear on what eric trump is
trying to accomplish
by doing interviews but he was
interviewed last night on the sean
hannity
fox news propaganda program what he did
achieve
was creating a caricature of the
sycophantic
brown-nosing defender of donald trump
and in particular
a son who is desperate for the approval
of his father that he never really seems
to have gotten
it's sad in a way let's look at some
clips these are painful to watch
in this first clip eric trump rewrites
history
and says there has never been a more
beloved political figure
than donald trump i know in the history
of america
they know he did a great job for this
nation they know that there's never been
a more beloved political figure in our
country's
history there are 75 million americans
who would follow him to the end of earth
i mean
they love the man they love what he
stands for it's not just that trump
wasn't the most beloved political figure
there has been no president in the
modern political era
that was less popular than donald trump
donald trump not once during his entire
presidency
achieved a 50 percent approval rating in
the gallup daily tracking poll
that's never been the case for any
president in the history
of modern polling trump and melania
had the lowest average approvals of any
president and first lady for as long as
polling has been done
and eric trump it's just opposite
everything is
you know they wrongly talk about
orwellian uh and say things are
orwellian when they're really not
orwellian
double speak saying the opposite of what
is is true
actually is something that played a role
in george orwell's 1984.
eric trump says this is the most beloved
president in history
uh most never mind president he says the
most beloved political figure in history
and he is the least popular president in
history about whom we have data
then sean hannity tees up a softball for
eric trump
about how their victims the you know
melania is a victim
eric trump ivanka donald trump they're
they're
they're all treated so terribly and eric
trump still can't put together a
coherent answer
um but there's been nothing but from the
day
your father and melania trump came down
the escalator trump tower it's been
never-ending harassment for your dad
your
you your family don jr
ivanka every baron even melania
everybody
and it continues now we know the outcome
of this latest charade
i played the double standard and i'm
just curious as you hear the remarks of
democrats and compare them to the
remarks of your dad
what your thoughts are
sean i was there you know 20 minutes
after election 20 minutes after election
day
on in you know 2016 it was a beautiful
day i remember
the washington post writing that story
which is this is the you know this is
the minute that
impeachment begins and they tried and
they tried to get him with the russia
hoax and they tried to get him with
ukraine and they tried to take down
kavanaugh and they tried to get him
again
and they tried to manufacture everything
you know under the sun against my father
against all of us they do it every
single day they continue to do it
ah the poor trump family
have you ever seen a more privileged
set of people portray themselves
as bigger victims and martyrs than this
family
josh hawley being on fox news every
other day
speaking to a national audience about
how he's been silenced
yeah that's funny this is even crazier
and they claim
to be tough they don't want snowflakes
all of this nonsense
and they are the thinnest skinned family
who have spent four i mean really five
years now
obsessed with the idea that nobody's
being
been treated worse than them there's
been no bigger victims
in america in the world than the trump
family the most powerful person in the
world for four years
and his family want you to think
they are the victims of everything of
the media
of the democrats of whatever it's
unbelievable
last clip eric trump says
that the country is soon going to miss
donald trump and honestly i think people
are going to miss donald trump
really quickly i think they're going to
miss him really really quickly because
some of these policies that they're
enacting these executive orders
you know 40 40 in the first day um are
madness sean they're just madness
well you know it's it's interesting
again trump left
office with the lowest approval of his
presidency
he was the least popular president in
the history of the modern political era
but in addition eric is just lying on
the facts and this is a good opportunity
to talk about the executive orders eric
there said that
joe biden signed 40 executive orders on
his first day in office this is not true
the list of executive orders is public
any one of you can find it it's out
there on january
20th joe biden signed nine executive
orders
nine not forty you might like those
executive orders
you might not you might wanna reform the
executive order system
but he didn't sign 40 executive orders
on day one he signed
nine on the second day of his presidency
joe biden signed
eight executive orders eric trump says
it was 40 on day one
actually it was 17 over two days and in
total
including the executive orders joe biden
signed yesterday on immigration
joe biden has signed 28 executive orders
in 14 days not 40. you can debate
executive orders
you can debate their contents you can
debate their merits you can debate
what shouldn't shouldn't be done via
executive order is there something
damaging to the political system to the
fact that every president feels the need
to use executive orders to undo what
their predecessor did
all valuable debates but if you start
with a lie
that joe biden signed 40 on day one when
he really signed nine
the debate is worthless because you're
starting with a lie truly
a pathetic figure in american politics
and
that could apply to a lot of people i'm
talking about eric
trump and i'm wondering is he going to
keep doing this for the next two years
for the next four years
appearing on fox news to talk about how
everybody misses his dad and how
terrible joe biden is and i think it's
still a question mark
it's looking like donald trump is just
sort of disappearing we've not heard
from him for two weeks
when it comes to eric trump don jr has
been going absolutely crazy
on twitter for the last two weeks
there's rumor
or the idea that maybe eric trump's wife
lara trump
plans to run for senator in north
carolina still a question mark as to
whether these characters are going to
try to keep playing a role in american
politics let's hope they don't and again
the entire eric trump thing eric trump's
entire presence to me
wreaks of a son desperate for their
father's approval
more than anything else